Rhodium is a metal which is used very widely
in catalysts. It is
particularly important in chemical reactions
such as the one
that makes ethanoic acid, that is one of the
components of
vinegar, but it is made industrially from
carbon monoxide and
methanol. And the key components to make this
reaction
work are rhodium compounds, but like many
of the elements
in this part of the periodic table, rhodium
is a very rare metal.
It’s not very widely found in nature and
therefore it is really
quite expensive and I have been to a catalyst
manufacturer
and been shown a large vat which they said
has a half a
million pounds of rhodium compound in, and
when you
actually look in there is a remarkably small
pile of material at
the bottom.